quick demo of this video tutorial this
is a mean stack big nails tutorial in
this tutorial we will develop a mean
stack application from scratch to
implement cred operations insert update
and delete in order to insert a new
employee you can do this
now click on submit so here we have
inserted a new employee inserted
employees will be listed inside this
table here in order to update a record
you can click on this pencil icon here
instead of UK I will update Linda now
click on submit so here you can see the
toss message updated successfully here
we have updated in this table list also
so these employer of course are inserted
into this employees collection in
MongoDB here if you want to delete a
record you can click on this delete icon
here it will ask for confirmation are
you sure to delete this record or not
click on OK so here we have the liturgy
record for Fiona green so from this
tutorial you can learn how to develop an
underpriced application in main stack so
please watch till the end of this video
tutorial so here is my BS code editor I
will be using this idea for the
application development you can use any
IDE as you wish
basically it means like application we
will have no jsapi in server side and as
a server we will use NPM package Express
for database we will use no SQL MongoDB
and finally we will have the client side
it will be implemented in angular 5
before starting this project we have to
ensure that we have a working mean stack
development environment first of all we
need no js' itself for that you can go
to this website no js' dot o then you
have to download the installation file
as per your operating system in my case
I have Windows operating system with
64-bit so we have to download either of
these two files here we have the stable
version and here we have the beta
version better download this terrible
version 8.11 point 1 node.js
installation is so simple you can
complete the installation process by
pressing a bunch of next buttons in the
installation wizard after installation
just open command prompt then type the
command node space - V hit end up so
here you can see the latest in solution
in my system I have already installed
node.js 8.11
one after Nadia is we have MongoDB first
of all go to this website MongoDB com
then click on download here then go to
community server then select the
installation file as per your operating
system in my case I have windows so I
can download this MSI installer file
installation of MongoDB is also simple
you just need to go through a few next
buttons after installation we need to
start MongoDB for that we need to know
the installation directory where we have
installed MongoDB in my case I have
Windows operating system so it would be
the in programs files so here is my seed
drive inside that we have programs file
and here we have the MongoDB folder
server
3.6 bin folder here we can see the file
Mon Gordy dot exe in order to start the
server we have to run this application
from our command prompt
so let's look how we can do that in
order to starve a MongoDB we have to
navigate inside this folder for that in
command prompt you have to run this CD
command after running this command will
be inside this for the directory here
bin folder from the we have to run this
[ __ ] d dot exe file using this command
in order to run this file we have to
pass this command-line argument DB part
here we have a folder path to a folder
[ __ ] - dot data you can name before now
and you can keep the folder anywhere you
wish basically inside this folder
MongoDB will store the files related to
the database that we have created ok in
my case it is here [ __ ] - dot data so
whenever we want to work with more DB we
have to start the server using these two
commands here in order to make the
process more simple I have saved these
two commands in a notepad then go to
file then save as then name the file
here finally you have to add the
extension dot b.a.p then click on save
in my case I have already saved this
file in my desktop you just need to
double click on this file so that it
will start the MongoDB so here we have
started the MongoDB
with this batch file so here we have
installed and started MongoDB server now
we need a management tool in order to
work with MongoDB in latest versions of
MongoDB it comes with a default
management tool here this MongoDB
compass or you can use this software
Robo [ __ ] okay so in my case I will be
using this one default management tool
MongoDB compus community double-click on
it in order to connect with MongoDB we
have a connection wizard here it is
already filled with default
configurations since we have no change
from default configuration we just need
to click on this connect button here as
a first step towards the application
development let's create a database for
that you can click on this create
database button here then you have to
name the database I will name this
database as square DB to create a
database in MongoDB kombis management
tool we need to have at least one
collection so I will name the collection
as employees ok if you are not familiar
with Noyce ql database collection means
tables in SQL database table rows in SQL
database is treated as a record in Noyce
ql database column in SQL database is
treated as a field in noise QLD B so
here we have the collection employees
inside that we will have a number of
course related to each employee now
let's create the database click on
create database so here we have the
newly created dB for now we don't have
any record inside this employees
collection now back to require
software's for means tag app development
here we have the angular CLI for
angularfire development we need to
install angular CLI in order to install
the package you can use this command npm
install minus g then angular CLI so
that's it here we have a means tag app
development environment now back to vs
code editor first of all we will create
a server-side app with no J's after that
we will implement
the client-side using and qualify so I'm
going to create a mean stack application
from scratch inside this project folder
so first of all we have to open this
folder in my vs code editor so let me
copy this for the path from here then
back to the vs col then go to file open
folder then paste the directory here hit
enter then click on select folder now
let me create a new folder for node.js
application I will name this folder as
node.js then go to this folder node.js
we have to open command prompt inside
this folder directory for that you can
use the shortcut
hold shift then right-click on Mouse
then click on this open command window
here in order to create a node.js
application first therefore we have to
have a packaged or JSON file in order to
create the packaged or JSON file you can
use this command npm in it hit enter
then it will ask configuration details
about the project package name will be
no js' hit enter then version
description entry point test command
leave it as it is hit enter so here we
have created a packaged or json file it
is filled with these default
configuration is this okay
type yes here then hit enter so you can
see the newly created packaged or JSON
file here in order to work with this
nodejs application we need some NPM
packages we need NPM package Express to
act as a server then we need Mongoose it
will act as a MongoDB ORM finally we
have body posture it allows us to send
JSON data to node J is API so let's
install these packages NPM install first
of all we have Express Mongoose after
that we have body - possum now we need
to save these dependencies inside
package dot JSON file for that you can
do this - - save hit enter so here we
have successfully installed these three
cages mongoose express body posture now
let's start coding inside this
application we have already created a
MongoDB crud DB here now we are going to
connect the database from this node.js
project for that I'm going to create a
new file here I will name this file as
DB dot J's in order to connect MongoDB
we will use NPM package Mongoose that we
have already installed so first of all
we need a request statement for mumbles
so here it is here we have a constant
Mongoose it requires Mongoose package
after that we can make the connection
using the object mongoose by calling
this function connect as a parameter for
this function we can pass the mode DB
connection details here we have more DB
protocol than localhost we have
installed this package inside this
default port number two seven zero one
seven after that we have the database
name cred DB after the mobo DB
connection we can call a callback
function like this it has a single
parameter er our it stores possibly
errors while connecting the database if
there is no error we will print this
message into console window more DB
connection succeeded if there is any
error we will print this message error
in DB connection with detailed error
object we have called this JSON string
if I function in order to convert this
object into a string with in the nation
of two space character most of the case
we need to establish MongoDB connection
outside this DB dot JS file so we need
to export this constant Mongoose for
them we can do this module dot exports
is equal to Mongoose now let me save
this file then open command prompt here
in order to run this DB dot J's file we
can do this no space
DB dot J s hit enter sorry here we have
created this DB dot J as file outside
this no J's folder now let me move this
file into this no J's folder then back
to command prompt let me run this
command again hit enter so here you can
see the
MongoDB connections succeeded now if we
change something inside this no js'
project we have to rerun this
application inside this command form
using this nord command i'm going to add
two more dots at the end of this [ __ ]
DB connection succeeded message in order
to see these updates you have to rerun
this application for that use the
shortcut ctrl C twice then run the
command again so here we have the
updated dots now let's check how we can
avoid this execution restart after
application update for that we have to
install this NPM package Nordmann in
order to install this package globally
inside your system you can use this
command NPM install - G then node more
now let's look how we can use node more
now let me quit the current execution
for there you can use this shortcut ctrl
C twice then run this application using
Nordmann instead of node you know more
then VB dot J's hit enter so here we
have started this node J as project
using node more from now onwards we
don't want to we start this execution
after any updates inside this nodejs
project let me remove these two doors
from here then let me save this so here
you can see that Nordman already
restarted the application for new
changes now let's create the root
javascript file index dot J's first of
all we need request statement for
express and body posture so here it is
here we have a constant for express and
one for body posture also in order to
make a connection with MongoDB we have
to execute this DB dot J s module for
that we can add one more require
statement for DB gotcha is file here it
is always recommended to separate local
import and package import like this so
here we have a constant Momus it will
store the Mongoose that we have exported
inside this DV dot JS file here we have
used
restructurings index from es6 suppose if
you have an object or with these
properties P and
you in order to retrieve value of these
properties into a local variable P and Q
you just need to use this restructuring
syntax like this so that is what we have
done inside this project also inside
this DB dot JS file here we have
exported mom whose property in order to
retrieve that we have used Momus with
these structure in syntax with this
import we will establish a connection
with MongoDB in order to work with
Express package we have to call this
function Express like this so here we
have called the Express function result
will be saved inside this app variable
here now we have to configure Express
middleware in order to send JSON data to
this node J s project for that we can do
this we just need to call this AB dot
use function inside that we can pass the
result of this function execution body
posture dot Jason now in order to start
the Express server we can call the
function ab dot listen as a first
parameter we have to pass the port
number where we want to start this
application after starting the server
this callback function will be involved
inside that we have a message for
console window server started at port
number 3000 now let me save this index
dot JS file then open command prompt
here I want to run this application you
see Norman Norman space index board Jas
hit enter so here we have started the
Express server at port number 3000 and
we have successfully connected to
MongoDB now we are going to implement
crack operations insert update delete
and read or view using post update
delete and get web methods respectively
for that first of all we have to create
a model using Momus package so let me
create a models folder here models
inside that I will create a new file
employee door Jas first of all we need a
request statement for Mogis
so here it is here we have a constant
mongoose for mongoose package now let's
create the model employee
for that we can call the function
whose dog model inside that first of all
we have to pass the model name employee
here after that we have to specify the
schema or structure of our model so
inside this application we will
implement quirk operations using
employee details like name position
office and salary and here we have
specified the corresponding field types
all of these fields will be string
except this salary field finally we have
to export this employee like this modul
dot exports is equal to employee now in
order to insert new employer record into
MongoDB we just need to create an object
of employee and call the function say
from the object it will insert a new
record into this employee's collection
that we have already created so we have
not specified in order to insert the
record into this employee's collection
anywhere inside this model by default
Mongoose will insert the new record into
a collection with named employees so it
will use the plural version of model
name that we have passed here you don't
have to create the collection manually
in management tool like we do in SQL
databases mobis will automatically
create the collection as per our model
without using the plural version of this
model name we can pass a third parameter
here suppose I want to use a collection
with name EMP for this employee so we
can pass EMP as a third parameter here
or now we will use the employee's
collection now it's time to implement
actual crud operations insert update
delete and retrieve for that I am going
to create a new folder controllers here
controllers inside that we need to
create a new employee controller
employee controller dot J's inside this
employee controller we need to implement
router from Express for that first of
all we can add the require statement for
Express and then here we have created a
local variable for Express route of by
calling this out of function from X plus
constant inside this employee
Colome need to work with Momus model
employee that we have created here so
let's add a require statement for this
employee model also so here we have the
request statement and inside this
employee where you will be stored the
exported employee from this file now let
me add a router in order to retrieve all
employees from this employee's
collection for that we can create a get
request here so here we have the rod for
this get request when you saw make this
request we will call this function with
these two parameters request and
response inside the function we need to
retrieve all the course from this
employee's collection for that employees
dot find function can be called it will
retrieve all the employees from this
employees collection after retrieving
all those records we will call this
callback function with these two
parameters error and Docs so first of
all we will check if there is any error
or not if there is no error we will
pretend the documents that we have
received from this employee's collection
back to the response for that we have
called this send function from this
response object by passing these
documents that we have retrieved if
there is any error we will print this
message in console window error in
retrieving employees and here we have
concatenated the stringify version of
the error object that we have received
inside this callback function like this
gab requests we have to add few more
routes inside this employee controller
so we have to configure these routes
inside the root file indexed or js4 that
we have to export the router object that
we have created here modul dot exports
is equal to router now back to index dot
JSP l here first of all we have to add a
request statement for the employee
controller that we have added here so
here we have the request statement for
the controller with this employee
controller variable now in order to add
router from employees controller into
this application we can do this you will
call the middle wave function AB dot use
and we have the base URL for this
controller
employee so basically in order to
execute this get request we have to make
a get request like this localhost 3000
forward slash employees in order to
access routers from this employees
controller we have to append these
employees to the base URI localhost 3000
now let me append list into this router
then in order to make this get request
we can do this
employees forward slash list so here we
have appended employees to the base URL
and then here we have the route that we
have specified here for now we don't
need this list we will keep a single 4/4
retrieving all employees from the
collection now let me save all of these
files here
sorry inside this model we have a small
modification we have to export an object
like this employee is equal to employee
since we have same identifier on both
sides we can use the es6 shorthand
method we just need to pass employee
here now let me save all of these parts
here then you don't have to restart the
program inside the nor mode it will
automatically restart after making any
update inside this nodejs project now
let me try to make this request inside
the browser let me copy this and let me
open one more tab here hit enter so
basically with this get request you will
retrieve all the employees from this
employees collection unfortunately we
don't have any record inside this
employees collection so that is why we
have an empty era here so next we are
going to insert new employee record into
the DB collection for that we can define
one more route with post request like
this URI for this post request will be
same as that of this get request here in
order to make this post request you can
use the same URI like we have done in
get request during this post request we
will call this function with these two
parameters request Andrus
fons first of all we have to create an
object of employee model class like this
so here we have created an object of
employee model class as EMP inside that
we have filled because of the employee
from the request body basically for this
post request we will send a JSON data
containing details of new employee
so using that this and data we have
filled details of employees using
request Lord body object so in order to
retrieve the value of name property from
the send JSON data we can do this
request dot body dot name in the same
way we have retrieved other properties
also so here we have created an object
of mom whose model employee as EMP it is
filled with details of new employee now
in order to insert the new record into
MongoDB we can call this a function from
the mobile model object after saving the
record it will call this callback
function with these two parameters error
and document so if there is any error it
will be passed through this parameter if
the operation is successful
MongoDB will return an object containing
details of newly inserted employee with
these properties using this dog
parameter along with these properties
you will have an extra property
underscore ID MongoDB will use this
underscore ID property to uniquely
identify error code from a collection
it's like primary key in SQL databases
but it won't be in a sequence like 1 2 3
instead instead it will be a 24 hex
character string in length so first of
all inside this callback function we
will check if there is any error or not
if there is no error it will retain the
newly inserted dog back to the response
if there is any error we will print this
message into console window error in
employee save with the detailed error
object now let me save this file
Nordman will automatically restart
program here now we have to make this
post request we can't make the post
request from the browser like we do for
get requests for that we have to use a
special software's like postman so in my
system I have installed postman as an
extension for Google Chrome browser
inside that Here I am going to make a
post request you can select posts from
this drop-down then here we are going to
make a post request into this URL so
that we can copy this URL from here
itself URL will be same as that of get
requests so let me copy this and paste
in here now open body then select crop
we are going to send edges and data here
so here it is here we have an employee
details of Ashton Cox position will be
senior dollar per office London then we
have salary now click on send here so
here you can see the response from the
node.js application here so here we have
the details of new employee that we have
passed through this request and here we
have the underscore ID from my body
before this new record now let's take
MongoDB for this new record so here we
have the employees collection just click
on this refresh button here so here we
have the new record for Ashton course so
now we have a record inside this
employees collection now let me make
this previous get request it should
return all the employees from the
employees collection so let me reload
this page here so here we have the newly
inserted employee details in your
browser you may not see these much
internation for the response in my
system I have installed this and
formatter
so that's the reason we see these much
indentation here in your browser you may
see this response like this now I am
going to add one more get request into
this application so that it will return
a specific employee with given
underscore ID if we pass this ID we can
retrieve this whole employee duties for
that we are going to make a get request
like this
slash employees then ID that we have
saved here for that back to DVS code
editor now let's make a get request here
so here it is router door gate and here
we have the URI for this table in order
to make this get request along with this
URI you have to pass the ID underscore
ID for the corresponding employee record
when we make this get request we will
call this function with these two
parameters because and response like we
have done for the previous routes first
of all we have to make sure that the ID
pass through the URI should be a valley
MongoDB ID for that first of all we have
to import object ID from Mongoose as we
have done here first of all we will
check whether the ID is valid or not
in order to retrieve the value of this
ID from URI you can do this request
object or param then ID so here we can
check whether this ID is valid or not
for that we just need to call this
function is valid from this object ID if
it is not a valid ID we can return
status code 400 and we will send the
message nor a chord with given ID if the
even ID is valid we can a typical
spawning employee from the DB for that
we just need to do this employee door
fine by ID here we have used the
function find and here we have used fine
by ID so first parameter should be the
ID that we have received through this
URI here as a second parameter we can
pass this callback function with these
two parameters error and doc if there is
no error we will return the document
back to the response if there is any
error we will print the error message in
console window now let me save this now
let's try to make this get request so
here we have the ID for this new
employee let me
pitties replacing this ID here then hit
enter so here we have the employee
details of the newly inserted employee
so here we have the employee details
with given ID now we have to add two
more routes for update and delete now
let's try update operation for that we
have to use put web method so here it is
router dot put function can be called
and here we have the route for slash ID
parameter as a second parameter we will
call the function with these parameters
request and response inside the function
first of all we will check the ID pass
through the uri east valley port node
like we have done inside this get
request here okay if the ID is not valid
we will return the message no record
with given ID if the ID is valued we can
continue with update operation for that
for so far we will create an object like
this during update operation we will
send adjacent that are containing new
details of employees with that Jason we
have created a normal object here it's
not an object of the employee model that
we have done in post request instead it
is a normal object emp2 update the
employee given ID here we can do this
for that we need to call the function
find by ID and update as a first
parameter we have to pass the ID that we
have received from this URI here then we
have to do this it does the MongoDB we
have to update an employee with this ID
with these new informations inside this
object as a third parameter we can pass
an object with options like this I will
tell you what we meant by this property
here later as a last parameter we will
call the callback function like we do in
other Mongoose operations so here we
have the callback function with error
and dog parameter inside that we will
check
if there is any error or not if there is
no error we will return the dog back to
the response if there is any error we
will print another message in console
window so with this new option we test
the MongoDB whether we want to return
all data of employee or updated data of
employee back to the response so if nu
is equal to true this callback parameter
dog will have the value of updated
employed it is otherwise it will have
the old value of the corresponding
employee finally we have delete
operation for that we can add a new
route like this routered or delete
function for this route we have the URI
like this so when we make a request
delete request like this we can call
this function with these two parameters
request and response inside the function
first of all we will check whether the
ID pass through this URI is valid or not
otherwise we will delete the record by
calling this function find by ID and
remove so first parameter should be the
ID for that we can do this request dot
param stored ID after delete operation
we will call this callback function
inside that we can do this if there is
no error it will return the deleted
employee details back to the response
otherwise we'll print the error message
in console window so here we have
completed with nodejs project inside
that we have implemented all crud
operations using put post delete and
update now let's create angular
application for that we can use angular
CLI commands in command prompt since we
have already opened two command windows
form ODB and nodejs application I'm
going to use integrator terminal from
this IDE for that you can go to view
then integrator terminal here in order
to create and I will have five
application you can use this command ng
new then application name I will name
this application as angular app hit
enter so here we have successfully
created a client-side application as
part
of that here we have a folder angular
app inside that we have a brand new
angular 5 application now let's run this
application for that first of all we
have to navigate inside this folder so
we can use the CD command CD angular app
hit enter in order to run an angular
application you can use this command ng
served double - open hit enter so it
will compile and open your application
in your default browser so this is how
the fresh angular application looks like
by default angular applications uses
this port number four thousand and two
hundred in order to design this
application we will be using
materialized CSS for that we have to
include these references stylesheet and
JavaScript file in our application along
with that we need few icons for that we
will use material icons so back to the
application here then open index dot
HTML here so first of all we have the
stat sheet for material I CSS after that
we have stand sheet for material icons
before the body and tag we can add
script file for materialized thesis now
open style start CSS inside this - we
can add global CSS rules for the
application for now I will copy pasting
required CSS rules for this application
development inside this statute so here
it is now let's create required
components model and service classes
inside this application for that we need
1 more terminal so you can click on this
plus button here then navigate into the
angular application folder angular now
in order to create angular component you
can use this angular CLI command ng g 4j
c for component of name this component
as M Louie hit enter newly created
component can be seen inside this app
folder here now we need to add one model
and service class for that inside this
app folder I am going to add one more
folder I will name this folder as shared
now open
one terminal from this folder for that
right click on this folder then open in
command prompt here now let's create a
model class for that you can use this
command ng G for the rich and we need to
create a class in angular CLI there is
no specific command to create a model in
angular application but we can create
the model class by adding few tweaks
inside this class generation command
here we are going to create the employee
model class so I will name it as
employee then we have to add this
command line argument time is equal to
model hit enter you will e created model
class can be seen here employee dot
model dot TS after that we need to
create a service class also for that you
can use this command ng g4j r8s for
service we need to create employee
service class so I will just need to
type employee here hit enter now we can
start with employee model class so here
it is employee dot model dot TS inside
this model class we need to add
properties corresponding to this mobile
DB collection fields so we can add these
properties here ID name position office
and salary now open employee service
class first and foremost I am going to
add import statement for this service
class here here we have added import
statements for angular core packages and
Eric snakes along with that we have
important employee module from this
employee dot model dot TS file here now
let's create two variables inside the
service class so first of all we have
selected employee it's softy type
employee model class and here we have an
array of employee as employees so inside
this employees array we will save all
employees from the MongoDB collection
with the selected employee property we
will design a form for insert and update
operation that we can do in employee
component HTML default design of angular
application is rendered
here and this view is rendered from the
default component HTML which is app
component HTML here so I'm going to
remove these default HTML quotes from
here instead I will use the employee
component selector so here is the
component type script file I will use
this selector let me copy this then back
to app component dot HTML and I will add
a tag with this selector here now let me
save all of these modifications here
then back to the browser here you see
this angular application is already
restarted whenever we make changes
inside this angular application we don't
need to use external packages like we
have done in node.js with normal angular
CLI watch files inside this angular
application whenever we make a changes
inside them it will restart the program
here so here we have the paragraph
employee works from employee component
HTML now inside this component we are
going to design a form using the
property employee selected employee from
employee service class so first
therefore we have to inject employee
service class inside this employee
component type script file here we have
the type script file employee dot
component or TS for that first of all we
have to add an import statement for
employee service class so first of all
let me add a line break here so that we
can separate local import and built-in
import so here we have the import
statement import employee service from
shared folder employee service dot es5
in order to inject the service class we
have to add the class inside the
component providers array for that we
can do this here we have the providers
error inside that we have employee
service after that we need to add a
constructor parameter for employee
service like this private employee
service it's off the type employee
service class now let me save this file
then back to employee component dot HTML
file now we can design a form using this
employee service property selected
employee here we will wrap the employee
form inside a car
component from material I CSS you can
see examples for card component here now
back to here's code editor now let's
replace this default paragraph with a
card component so first of all we have a
div with class row and here we have the
grid system from material a CSS it is
almost similar to bootstrap grid system
inside that we have a deal with class
card inside that we have another deal
with class card content apart from that
we have one more class white - text so
this will apply white color for text
inside this deep inside that we have a
div row now we can use grid system from
materialized CSS we want to divide this
deal into two parts with five columns
and seven columns so here we have the
first deal and second you inside this
deal this first deal we will design the
employee form inside the second view we
will show employees list that we have
inserted into the MongoDB collection
here so first of all I will design
employee form inside this div so here we
have the form form here we have the
local reference employee form is equal
to ng form and here we have wired up the
submit even using ng submit attribute it
will call this function on submit and we
will pass the local reference employee
form into that function inside the form
first of all I will add a hidden field
inside this control we will store the
object ID from MongoDB so I will name
this control as underscore ID then we
have the local reference underscore ID
is equal to ng model and finally we have
to add the two-way data-binding here ng
model is equal to employee service that
means injected object of employee
service inside this component here then
we have selected employee inside this
employee service class and inside that
we have the property underscore ID from
employee model here now we need to add
input text box for remaining properties
for that you can see some
examples from the material I CSS
documentation here we will be using
liable text box pair like this we have
the label here and we have the text box
here now back to the vs code editor
first of all we need to add a div with
class row inside that we will have
another day with classes input field
called as 12 so it will take the entire
width inside this div row then we have
to add input control like this input
it's of the type text we can use this
control to end our employee full name so
I will add the name property here name
is equal to name and then here we have
the local reference name is equal to ng
model then we have the two-way
data-binding
ng model is equal to employee service
lord selected employee dot name so here
we are designing this form using
template driven approach after the ng
model we have to add placeholder
placeholder is equal to and full name
after that we have to add the label here
so here it is labelled inside that we
have name I want to make this input text
box as mandatory to indicate the
mandatory fees we will use air read a
strict mark for that I will add a nested
label inside this name level so here it
is if we have a level with class read
text so this a strict mark will have red
color we can add label text box per 4
remaining properties position of fees
and salary for that we can do this
so here we have the label text box pair
for position and then we have label text
box pair for office then finally we have
the salary text box so here we have
designed employee form using template
driven approach in order to work this
approach we have to add forms module
inside app module dot t as fun so first
of all we can add the import statement
for forms module here import forms
module from angular forms now we can add
this forms module inside the imports
array here
now let me save all of these
modifications and back to the
application here boom that's it here we
have an employee form as per our design
now we need to add a submit button and
reset button into this form for that
back to the component HTML here in order
to add these buttons we can add one more
deal before the form and tag here so
here it is we have a div with class pro
and we have another deal with input
field called as 12 inside that we have
two buttons this is for reset operation
and this is for the form submit button
for these two buttons we have classes
bTW and from material I CSS then we have
the custom class which we have defined
inside this tag stored CSS BTN - custom
in order to align these two buttons in
the right side we have added this right
class now let me save this and back to
the application here so here we have
added submit and reset button first of
all I will implement form reset
operation for that back to the component
type script file here employee component
or TS for that we will define reset form
function here it has a single parameter
form it's of the type ng form in order
to use this class we have to import
import ng form from angular forms we may
need to call this reset form function
from various parts of the application in
some cases we cannot pass value for this
form parameter so that is why we made
this parameter as nullable so first of
all we will check whether we have a
value for this form parameter if value
for this parameter is passed we can
reset this form by calling the reset
function like this form dot reset after
that we have to manually reset these
form controls since we have designed
this form using selected employee
property from employee service class we
can do this this dot employee service
dot selected employee key we have set
the selected employee property with an
object containing empty or null value
for those properties ID name position
office and salary now we can call this
result form function inside this ng on a
lifecycle hook and the on in lifecycle
hope will be invoked whenever this
component is fully loaded so initially
it would be better if we can reset this
form here for that we can do this this
dot reset form from this ng only
lifecycle hook we can't pass value for
this form parameter here so let me save
this and back to the application here
now we can wire up this reset form
function to this reset button click
event for that you can open the
component HTML here then we will add a
click event for this reset button here
so here it is we will call the reset
form function into that function we will
pass the local reference for this form
here okay now let me save this and back
to the application here now let's check
how this reset operation works for that
I will enter some random text inside
these text boxes here now click on reset
button here so here we have successfully
reset this form into its initial stage
now let's implement form validation as
we mentioned employee full-name is a
required field for this form submission
so that is why we have added error a
strict mark here in order to make these
textbox as required field we have to add
required attribute into the
corresponding input text box here so we
can add required attribute here required
now let me save this and back to the
application here we can implement form
validation using ng classes from angular
initially if you inspect this text box
here you can see that it has classes ng
pristine and ng invalid ng pristine
means we have not modified its initial
value ng in value class in the case that
this field is already invalid now keep
an eye on these classes here while we
update this text box
can see that its classes are modified ng
pristine is replaced with ng dirty and
ng invalid is replaced with ng valid if
I clear this text box you can see that
it has two classes ng dirty and ng
invalid we are not looking at ng touched
class Carolee we have ng dirty and ng
invalid class applied to this text box
so that is why we have a red bottom
border for this - box we have defined
this tile inside these tiles door CSS
file here if there is any input with
these two classes ng invalid and ng
dirty we will apply the bottom red
border now back to the application
whenever this form as a whole is not
valid I want to disable this submit
button so disabled attribute will be
applied whenever this form as a whole is
not valid and bluey form is the local
reference for this form here now let me
save this and back to the application
here initially this - box is empty and
thereby this form as a whole is not
valid so we have applied disabled
attribute to this submit button if I
enter something inside this - box you
can see that this submit button is
enabled now let's implement the form
submit even we have already added a
function to this form submit even here
ng submit we will call this function on
submit now we have to define this
function inside the corresponding type
script file here on submit function for
this function we have a single parameter
form it's of the type ng form inside
this on submit function we have to
insert a new employee into MongoDB for
that we need to consume post request
from the node.js API here so inside this
employee controller in our node.js API
we have created this post route we need
to consume this post route from this
angular application here from this
employee component in order to consume
post because we will create a function
inside this employee service class I
will name this function as post employee
for this function we have a single
parameter EMP it's of the type employee
Mori plus in order to make the post
request we have to make an HTTP request
into the node.js project for that we can
use HTTP client so first of all we have
to inject this HTTP client inside this
constructor here private HTTP it's off
the type HTTP client in order to work
with HTTP client we have to import HTTP
client module inside this app module dot
T is file so first of all I will add the
import statement for HTTP client module
and then I will add this class inside
this imports error here now back to
employee service class here now we need
to make the post request into employees
route for that let me create a read only
variable here so here we have the base
URL variable it is initialized with the
URI for the employee controller in our
node.js project now we can make a post
request for that we just need to call
the post function from HTTP client
object as a first parameter we have to
pass the URI so here it is then after
that we have to pass the days and object
EMP containing details of new employee
so here we have returned the result of
this post function back to the caller so
basically you can see that this post
function returns an absorber here so we
can call this function inside the
employee component dot es file here now
inside this component type script file
we can call this employee service
function post employee for that we can
do this this dot employee service door
post employee into this function we have
to pass an object of employee containing
details of new employee for that we can
do this here we have the form object in
order to retrieve value of form elements
we can do this form door value so it
will be an object of employee itself as
I told you this function post employee
will return an observer so we can
subscribe to that observable here inside
the SUBSCRIBE function we can define a
callback function like this it has a
single parameter response so it will
have the response returned from the no
js' project so first of all inside this
function after inserting a new record I
want to reset the form for that we can
call this reset form function by passing
this employee form object now I want to
show a toast notification saying
insertion is successful for that we can
use toast from this material I CSS go to
JavaScript there you can see toast here
in order to make a toast request we just
need to do this m dot toast inside that
we can pass this HTML object okay now in
order to make use of this M object
inside this angular application first of
all we have to declare M before this
component decoration here so here it is
here we have declared M it's off you
type in E now back to the function here
now we can make a toast request like
this M door toast here we have the HTML
same set in order to apply round border
you can use this class rounder now let
me save all of these modification and
back to the application here as you know
we have a node.js project running at
port number 3000 in order to achieve all
employees we can make this get request
from this angular application we are
going to consume a post request from
this node.js project where we have a
problem in order to make the request we
have to enable course inside the node.js
project course means cross origin
socially that means without cost
enabling any web application no js' or
any web application will block requests
from another web application which is
hosted in a different domain or port
number now in order to interact with
these angular and node.js project we
have to enable cores inside this nodejs
project for that first therefore we have
to install this NPM package course so
back to the command prompt here
currently it is running Nordmann let me
stop this execution for that you can use
the shortcut ctrl C then type Y in order
to install the package you can use this
command NPM install course and we have
to save this package in our packaged or
JSON file so we have double - save it
and off so here we have successfully
installed the cost package now back to
the no js' project here open index dot J
is file inside this file force therefore
we have to add the require statement for
course packet so here it is after that
we can use the middleware function Abdur
dues for that we can do this AB dot use
inside that we have passed this function
course so this will allow request from
any port number or domain we have to be
specific we need to allow request from
this angular application which is
running as poor number four thousand and
two hundred in order to enable course
for the angular application we can pass
an object inside this function like this
so here we have the origin property
inside that we have to enable cause for
this port number which is running at
localhost okay now let me save this and
back to the application here now let me
save these modifications here then back
to the command prompt now we need to run
this node.js project using node mod now
back to this angular application here I
am going to insert a new employee here I
will name this employee as Fiona green
then we have position it will be junior
developer
then office will be in Canada and we
have salary
click on submit so here you can see the
toast notification saved successfully
now if you check this MongoDB here now
we are inside the employees collection
click on refresh button here so here you
can see the new record for Fiona green
now inside this second div here I want
to display all employees from this
employees collection here for that back
to the angular application here then
open employee component HTML here inside
this deal we can add a table to list
employees in order to design the table I
will use the employees array from
employee service class here ok we have
already injected this employee service
inside the employee component type
script file here so we can make use of
that array inside this HTML here for
that for support we will add a table
here for this table we will apply two
classes from materialized CSS so first
of all we have responsive table after
that we have highlight class inside the
table first of all we will add the table
header for that we have t hat inside
that we need a row with columns for each
properties from the employees collection
after t hat we can display exact content
from employees collection for that we
have a TR element here here you can see
the ng for detective here it basically
allows us to iterate through the
employees array from employee service
clause with this EMP variable ok
so using this EMP variable we can
display status from this employees
collection for that we can do this first
of all we have the employee name in
order to display employee full name we
have used string interpolation or one
directional binding after that we have
position and office here inside this
employees are a from employee service
class we have to fetch all employee
records from this employees collection
for that we can define a new function
inside this employee service class here
so function will be something like this
get employee list here we have made a
get request into this node.js project
into this route here this one first row
so it will return all employees from
employees collection now we can call
this function from this angular
component employee component here for
that I'm going to define a new function
here function name will be refreshed
employee list inside the function we can
call this function get employee list for
that we can do this this dot employee
service not get employee list
it basically returns an observable from
this get function here so we can
subscribe to that observable here so we
will call the SUBSCRIBE function inside
the SUBSCRIBE function we can define a
callback function with a single
parameter response now inside this
response parameter we will have an array
or a course from this employees
collection so we can assign that array
into these employees or here for that we
can do this this dot employee service
not employees is equal to response here
you can see a red squiggly line because
we are assigning an object into
employees array so we have to cast this
response as an employee arrive for that
force so for we have to add an import
statement for employee model like this
then we can cast this response like this
as employee array now I will call this
function inside the ng Oni lifecycle
hook here this dot refresh employee list
now let me save all of these
modifications here then back to the
application so here you can see the
Employee List that we have inserted into
this MongoDB collection now I want to
add one more column into this table for
some action buttons like edit and delete
so back to the component HTML file here
so first of all I will add an empty
column inside
we'll head down like this then inside
this TRL MN we can add an extra TD like
this inside that we will add a button
for delete operation like this so it has
a class custom class action BTN it is
defined inside the sky stored CSS inside
the element we have a material icon for
edit operation so it will show a pencil
icon after that we need to add an anger
element for delete operation so here it
is we have the custom class action BTN
and here we have the material icons for
delete operation so it will be a trash
icon now let me save this and back to
the application here so here you can see
those two buttons here edit and delete
operation now let's implement the update
operation in order to update error code
you so want to click on this pencil
button here then we will show the
corresponding record details inside this
form here after making the update then
you sir can submit before so first of
all we have to implement V click even
for this pencil button here so let me
add a click even here when we click on
this angered element we will call this
function on edit by passing this EMP
object from the I tration now let me
define this function inside the type
script file here on edit it has a single
parameter EMP it's of the type employee
model class inside that we just need to
set this employee object in to the
selected employee property of employee
service class so that it will update
this form with selected employee content
so we can do this this dot employee
service dot selected employee is equal
to e MP now let me save all of these
modifications and back to the
application here if I want to update
this record for fee on a green you can
click on this pencil button here so here
we have populated details of employee
fee on agree
we can edit the employee details here
then submit the form we have already
implemented submit event for this form
using this onsubmit function here so
inside this function we have to deal
with insert and update operation but we
will decide whether we want to do update
operation or insert operation based on
the value of this input hidden field
here underscore ID if underscore ID has
an empty string then we will go for
insert operation otherwise we will go
for update operation for that we can add
and if course here form dot value dot
underscore ID if it is equal to empty
string we will do the insert operation
here in the else part we have to do the
update operation for update operation we
have to consume put route from nodejs
project in order to consume the request
I am going to add a new function inside
this employee service class here so here
we have the function put employee it has
a single parameter EMP it's off the cut
employee in order to consume the put
route from nodejs we can call the put
function from HTTP client object as a
force parameter we will pass the URI
here here we have concatenated
underscore ID into the base URL like
this as a second parameter we have
passed the exact employee object now we
can make use of this function inside
this employee component type script file
here it would be same as that of this
post employee function invocation so let
me copy this and paste it inside this
else part here then instead of this post
employee we have put employee function
inside this toast success function we
can show updated successfully after
insert or update operation we have to
refresh this employee list inside this
table for that we can call this function
refresh employee list so
we will do this this dot refresh
employee list function can be called
same function can be called inside this
function also let me save all of these
modifications here then back to the
application I'm going to update this
Fiona Glee in the code
now click on this pencil icon here then
instead of Canada I'm going to update
that with UK click on submit so here we
have the success message updated
successfully now back to the MongoDB
combis management tool here you can see
the old office of Fiona as Canada if you
refresh this list it should be updated
to UK finally we have to deal with
employee delete operation for that we
will be using this delete icon here so
we have to wire up and even for this
button click even back to component HTML
here then I will add a click even for
this delete button here we will call
this on delete function into that
function we have to pass two parameters
first of all we will pass the underscore
ID for the MongoDB object and then we
will pass the form object employee form
because we have to reset this form after
any delete operation now we need to
define a function inside this employee
service class in order to consume delete
route from node.js project for that we
can do this we have the function delete
employee it has a single parameter
underscore ID we will make this delete
request by passing this URL inside that
we have appended this underscore ID now
back to the component type script file
here now we can define this on delete
function here function name will be on
delete it has two parameters underscore
ID then for Billy to operation is a loss
of data so we have to confirm the
operation from client site for that we
can do this we will have any close
inside that we will confirm the
operation by asking this question are
you sure to delete this record or not if
you sir confirm this operation it will
a true value so inside this if closed we
are safe to delete the record for that
first of all we will call the function
delete employee from this employee
service cross function into that
function we have passed this underscore
ID value this function will return an
absorber so we can subscribe to that
function here inside the SUBSCRIBE
function we will have a callback
function with a single parameter
response after deleting an employee we
have to refresh this employee list here
for that we can call the function
refresh employee list then we will reset
this form if there is an employee
selected for update operation for that
we can do this this dot reset form
function can be called with this form
object finally we have to show the toss
message m dot tossed inside that we will
show this message deleted successfully
now let me save all of these
modifications then back to the
application here I'm going to delete
Ashton Cox record for that you can click
on this trash icon here then it will ask
for confirmation are you sure to delete
this report click on OK
so here we have successfully deleted the
record if you check the MongoDB combis
tool you can refresh this list here so
here we have deleted Ashton Cox record
so with this means sack application we
have implemented curve operations so
let's mind up this means tag tutorial
for business you can download this
project from the github link given in
video description please like and share
this video with your friends and
colleagues so that they can benefit from
this have a nice day bye